so I became a twitch streamer by the way
every game we play I give away prizes
this week it was season 10 battle passes
so I thought that showing you one of the
games we played hide-and freeze here's
the rules everyone meets up and is given
one minute to hide anywhere on the
island once that one minute is over I
can come and crush their dreams but
here's the best part
the hiders can only move when the storm
moves so as soon as that time it turns
blue
they must freeze in whatever position or
hiding-place they are in praying they
are not found by their the seeker it's
simple enough isn't it so let's do this
hide and freeze so you have one minutes
before I come and find you and kill you
off you go
[Music]
once you're hiding you can only move
when the storm moves okay what's going
on what are you doing ma'am are you
doing no thanks I'm not this not this
week
[Music]
thank you all right all right I'm coming
for you now good luck everyone
I'll be using the the replay theater
afterwards because I'm sure I'll run
past so many people and you can be just
like laughing there what we're gonna do
I'm do thank you so much for playing you
are the first real kill me yes how are
you doing brother
thank you very much for coming I really
appreciate it don't worry if you can't
play this time the plan is at least
every two weeks I'm hoping every week at
some point we just meet up and just give
things away so as as the stream grows
the gifts will grow better
[Music]
I'm hoping in replay theater this will
be quite funny because there'll be some
people just stood there they'll walk
straight past them like an idiot someone
in dusty thank you on my way
[Music]
you know three seconds two seconds one
second you can no longer move you are
stuck wherever you are for two whole
minutes do not move
and here's someone
it's a bloody drone goddamnit something
around here where would you hide
somebody here is somebody here I heard
heard someone where is it
I'm sure it was there it must be
upstairs good chance are the Reaper
[Laughter]
brilliant one freely at all perfect I
mean thank you very much Jen no Lee and
sooc thank you very much excellent hide
in gents thank you for playing along
much appreciated
right you can move for one minute 54 I
will shoot you know if I see you you
shall be shot
[Music]
ha ha GG's any emotes idiom up nice
thank you very much for playing it is
much appreciated have an awesome day I
suppose are you doing dude you have 51
seconds to move good luck with your
hiding spot for damage your wrecked
right the hiding places are gonna get
good now you'll have 26 seconds to keep
moving I don't think this guy
understands the rules
give me an emotes yeah thank you very
much for playing I appreciate that
another one that's ready
thank you very much played anonymous he
doesn't want to know the one you don't
know what his name is
we're getting close
seven or seven after 37 this is gonna be
a massacre not to find bullets
Hey hi guys thank you for playing were
you thank you give me an emote please Oh
heartbreaking thank you very much
good to see you Gigi literally Gigi in
that case his name was Gigi you can't
write these things right you have one
minute to move how fast that I've never
shot this far but there nope
close but no cigar so many so many let's
follow up in 38 seconds of movement
let's good luck with your hiding spots
be creative
sometimes obvious is created by the way
use the visual noise I don't be cheating
wouldn't it good nicely done well and
like enter me sir
oh that's clever to our gliders give me
a vote give me a vote thank you very
much x-ray guy pretty shy for a Rygaard
I will save the replay I will save the
replay and I will look at what everyone
did I'm gonna try and get a video up
tomorrow for about this what are you
doing boss what is he doing
I'm gonna go see what this one is doing
first
ah clever you know what I want to get
well you let your live for you live it's
art you can go you live you survive the
shop go oh thank you very much for
playing Arkham Knights good to see you
if you weren't together that first
person I wouldn't have found you
it was the second person walking over so
in this game mode it's a good a good
idea to him
stay solo what what what really it well
done you gave it away you need just a
suppressed weapon so if you can find a
suppressed pistol it's really good to
taking trees down without notice or
structures down really an brilliant work
though
53 seconds of movements I shall shoot
you if I see you so close so close
how'd you like this game er what do you
think do it hello there
oh it's a goody mob thank you very much
for playing thank you for being real and
not being a plonker you're perfect to me
right where was the one with it
this is what I want this is what I call
fair and fun and hopefully the reward is
small enough that people don't take this
too seriously because if it's too big
you get people cheaper this is how can
you get people cheating with good you
know if he didn't move if you didn't
move you out that it was so close if you
didn't move you were there Queeny ass if
you didn't move
you had me 16 seconds 16 seconds well I
see look I like you style to heal thank
you very much
it's great to play korosensei Oh Oh
sensei Hey
so he pronounced it whoever is someone
go ask somebody else troll bait mage
what are you doing milady
what are you doing it's my job to murder
people watch like dude all right I
believe now you can keep moving unless
it the timer goes blue this is
completely a game of look
good squilliam wag maracas warrior your
alleged how are you oh you almost go
[Music]
the woods
thank you very much for playing oh you
brought me a scarf
well done now you're building something
to be you then here
try not to build if you can resist keep
moving try to move behind people get
them killed before you using the launch
buddy boys missing shots now always
fight it
oh [ __ ] five did know that there are
also five minute they're all taking Hill
I appreciate that
we once it who wants it
[Music]
No
I'm gonna die by your game bud
Columbia tank that was close oh it's
gonna become slack
who's left to left we have a winner we
have a winner
well done come and come over here please
if you would
you may bludgeon me to death if you can
but we got a fear of a weapon kill me
dude kill me
he'll do it kill me who was that it was
there was anonymous how he can't win if
you're anonymous hopefully in the replay
I can see your name but thank you very
much so
Game one what do you think how does his
work enjoying this this terrible this
could I'm just trying to think of
different types of video we can do and
ways to give you stop so we have a
winner I don't know who it is I might
check on the replay well that was it so
I wasn't down what should we do next
[Music]